this is Jonathan Ferguson the keeper of
firearms and artillery at the Royal
armories Museum in the UK which houses a
collection of thousands of iconic
weapons from throughout history and on
this week's episode well we're showing
you find people a whole host of unseen
footage from across the last year these
are all weapons that for one reason or
another never made it into the Final
Cuts of their respective episodes but
are here now for your viewing pleasure I
do think the popularity of Accuracy
International rifles in video games is
worthy of comments in itself they are I
would say disproportionately represented
in video games and I think it's because
they look cool we've got a lot of great
stuff planned for 2023 but do let us
know in the comment section down below
what games or guns you'd like to see
Jonathan break down right let's get into
this selection of cut guns
okay for some reason this thing's called
The Mark 18 ABR which smacks of a
legally different name we're used to
that of course in gaming I don't really
understand that here though because that
is a military designation and there is
no copyright issue over military
designations it's not a big deal except
that in a sort of sim like this that's
gonna irritate I'm sure some of the
players at least what it should be is
the mark 14 and what makes the naming
thing especially weird is that there is
a mark 18 the little short-barreled M4
variant effectively so I don't really
understand that ABR should be EBR for
enhanced battle rifle which makes me
Twitch slightly because I don't like the
term battle rifle 762 millimeter yes
that's 762 NATO as I'm sure most people
watching this will already know the mark
14 is a slightly renamed derivative of
the M14 the 1960s well 50s vintage 762
NATO service rifle the caliber ever
carried over the barreled action carried
over the actual rendition of the girl in
the game I haven't really got much to
say it looks good performs as we'd
expect it to really
bit of an action movie favorite of the
moment the origin 12 from of course
Modern Warfare 2019 still I would say
going strong but it didn't seem to be
very effective there yeah okay short
barrel but it's still 12 gauge so I'd
have thought it would be a little bit
more effective then again clearly
Warzone has got quite a strong armor
feature in it let me see somebody
putting ceramic plates into their vest
at one point so 12 gauge shotguns are
potentially absolutely devastating even
in the military scenario but
um you aren't necessarily going to
incapacitate somebody with a shot from
one of them compared to say a full power
rifle feels a little bit weak it looks
cool it sounds good the side grip is
kind of fun and not completely
impractical but it doesn't really make
that much of an impact in gameplay
foreign
[Music]
is the Vernal Austrian design
1877 variant of the 1873 original and I
just grabbed the carbine version because
that's what we have in this building but
the action is identical yeah somewhat
improved from the 1873 version and it's
as you see here very well done except
that on the reload so we have to pull
back the hammer slightly as shown open
it up with this Wing to it to effect
extraction we don't Yank on the Block
like we do for a Snyder which is what
appears to be happening here all we do
there's hammer on that like if it's a
stuck case bash on that and just that
extra rotation causes
the extractor
to pop out and prize the rim clear of
the breech face it's a quite an
interesting slick system for an early
breach loader or if it would be if it
was 1860s or 70s absolutely thoroughly
obsolete by 1914 needless to say
[Music]
we've got our Mad Max double barrel
shotgun not particularly remarkable
except for the twin spiked breaching
muzzles which is what those are designed
for so on a single barrel shotgun
typically those are jammed into the wood
or the plastic of a door and then um
that stops the muzzle from slipping when
you fire it to blow out the hinge which
is how you actually get through a door
typically not um not by shooting it down
but having said that they do look quite
brutal and of course they would be more
effective than just a bare muzzle at
poking people in the face as a sort of
bayonet substitute and that is reflected
in the game in terms of increased melee
damage now it is it's called a spiked
muzzle brake and it looks like it might
have some ports in it but I can't see it
doing much to to function as a brake
which is unfortunate because the recoil
of a sawn off double barrel shot shotgun
is significant and it might actually be
helpful to have some sort of compensator
or break on there
yeah the good old classic MP5 if you're
ever debating what weapons are the most
suitable in a zombie apocalypse so there
are various reasons why this might not
be the best choice but in terms of
controllable automatic fire if that's
what you require for your zombie head
shotting needs I don't think there's
much better around than the MP5 this is
pretty standard MP5 A5 retractable stock
three round burst trigger group it's got
some concessions to modernization so
that we can fit accessories of course
which is something you can get now on
mp5s the classic polymer handguard has
been replaced with a quad rail which
again is something we do see on those
few users that are still using mp5s
these days still still made still
popular uh just being pistol caliber
it's as we've discussed before here its
role has largely been supplanted by
short rifles but it's nice to see it
it's one of my favorite designs and it
seems to handle pretty well
the the B and T Universal service weapon
if I remember rightly this was conceived
of as a and I suppose as the name
implies a police or Security Service
weapon that you can holster on your hip
as a pistol and shoot like a pistol but
then flick out the stock and give
yourself a significant advantage in
terms of stability of firing position to
use it like a little carbide but it's a
very interesting gun to see this has got
to be its first appearance in a video
game and possibly in any kind of media
although I'd have to check
next up the rpk 74 for those of you
aren't aware but tell right away just
from looking at the game model but this
is essentially an AK-74 on steroids the
the giveaway on the um
receiver is this reinforced area here on
the stampings around the trunnion this
is this is reinforced to take excessive
heat for more sustained fight it's a
machine gun after all the barrel is
heavier and also longer it has a bipod
of course came with the extended 40
round magazine now the weapon won't
actually sit upright when that magazine
fitted it has to lay on its side but the
bipod accommodates for that and this
club shaped buttstock which is designed
to let you pull it into the shoulder
when you're aiming it as a true like
machine gun can of course be used as a
glorified rifle and with an optic like
this a sort of DNR really
thank you
still standing
oh check your fire bit of a I won't say
emerging trend of a bit of a trend with
revolvers in modern games is that they
should look funky and that reflects the
trend in the real Firearms industry that
um what was once the staple of Target
star revolvers is now I think more
commonly found even if you're not
intending to use the thing for target
shooting so this is the um Smith and
Wesson MMP which originally stood for
military and police but it's the
performance center version of the model
327 and unlike many Magnum revolvers
depicted in-game or revolvers full stop
shown in games this one does function
correctly albeit in double action only
not we're not shown any single action
firing but then in this situation you're
highly unlikely to do that I would
suggest so in other words pull through
on the trigger the cylinder revolves and
the hammer Cox and releases all in one
go which requires um releasing quite a
lot of engineering and ideally some hand
finishing to make it really slick quick
to operate smooth both quick easy to
pull and therefore accurate as well
suffice to say it's a little bit Gucci
This use but hey someone had one lying
around or they found one somewhere why
wouldn't you use it it's powerful it's
got a lot of penetration behind those
rounds so the old the classic destroy
the brain thing is going to be a much
more of a I was going to say dead search
but that would be a terrible pun
I mean another another gun that makes me
sad because we don't have it is the Sig
Sauer MPX I think I've got my hands on
one of these at Shot Show in 2013. I'm
struck by how Hefty it it felt which is
not something that really translates to
to video games so that the MPX is is a
modern take on the submachine gun taking
a lot of lessons from well uh assault
rifles essentially so it's got the
ergonomic solving armor light and AR-15
uh it's got a short straight gas system
like things like the HK 416 have and the
MCX rifle that Sig also make that's what
makes it a little heftier that in the
fact that unlike say the UMP which is
super light being as plastic as h k
could make it this thing is all metal
albeit as lightweight as they can make
it but because it has a gas system on it
which makes it pretty bomb proof of
reliability wise makes it a bit heavier
so just something that occurred to me
because you can't really you can model
weight with like weapons Sway and how
easy it is to get your get your
crosshairs On Target what you can't get
is the feel of something heavier
[Applause]
this one is a bit more plausible in
terms of what you might find in Eastern
Europe you know if it's something that's
whether you're buying it from a dealer
you know you can imagine a situation
where you could get hold of almost
anything potentially especially in a
fantasy horror game but the the 1897
Winchester shotgun this is the riot
version with the bayonet Shield uh
bayonet mount on the heat shield it's
reasonable to suppose that there'd be
some of these still knocking around
albeit they'd probably be sold as very
valuable collectors items rather than
gussied up and supplied to you in this
game and the version we saw there was
obviously incredibly gussied up
um engraved and plated and all sorts
which I mean thankfully I've never seen
anyone do that to an 1897 pump and if
they did it would make me cry I suspect
right here
this is a lesser known German sniper
rifle built on the Finnish Sarco action
it's a volt action rifle the um Sarco
and known for their precision rifle
actions uh so this company marries that
to a Precision Barrel in a stock of I
think their own design not not borrowed
from anywhere else and this is pretty
much how Precision rifles are designed
and built these days with with some
exceptions of wholly original designs
Accuracy International for example
although they they will use even they
will use chassis systems from other
companies it's almost like a throwback
to the the flintlock days where you
wouldn't necessarily make the barrel or
the lock or even carve the stock but you
would be the gun maker who puts all that
together into the finished gun that's
not quite the case here but because they
are building their own actions but this
is the sort of semi-boutique nature of
sniper rifles true Precision sniper
rifles
handgun here
all right so I left for dead Uzi makes a
return but this time it's the Mini Uzi
the medium-sized Uzi rather than the
full-size classic from the original two
games and it's a bit of an odd choice
because although they've gone for that
very compact almost machine pistol sized
submachine gun does still have a butt
stop though they've put on it a what
would be in reality a 16-inch civilian
legal barrel to make it a rifle in many
countries which would mean that it was
semi-automatic only so they've Shrunk
the gun that they made the barrel longer
than the original Uzi so slightly
curious and it is of course full auto so
I guess I don't know if the idea is does
look like yeah I see the selector
markings just for R and S so I do
believe the idea is this is somebody's
sort of range toy semi-automatic nine
millimeter mini uzi with Optical sight
mounts and Laser Mount but they haven't
done the paperwork to make it short
barreled or whatever so someone's put
some thought in here as to what weapons
would be available in this scenario and
what someone might do to them to make
them zombie apocalypse fit so some
interesting backstory that we can read
from the design of this gun I think
ah my old Nemesis the bfr revolver from
Magnum Research and um taking advantage
of that very long cylinder which does
fire 4570 ammunition to fire whatever it
is the sniper rifle in this game fires
it's unusual in a way to have more than
one big powerful Magnum revolver but
from what I understand some of these are
unlockable only by beating the game on a
certain difficulty or something so it's
not wildly messing up gameplay balance
unless you want it to and you work hard
unlock it and then splits through using
that although it didn't seem wildly
effective considering it's firing rifle
rounds of course firing rifle rounds
from such a short barrel gives you
diminishing returns because you've still
got lots of recoil and a big heavy
bullet and a lot of powder but you're
not getting the same degree you're
losing significant muzzle velocity from
a short barrel relative to the rifle
it's designed for yeah just a
controllability goes someone out the
window so there's a reason why pistols
tend to fire pistol ammunition Mission
and rifles tend to fight rifle
ammunition
I do think the popularity of Accuracy
International rifles in video games is
worthy of comments in itself because
they're not they are pretty wide
spreaders Precision rifles around the
world but because Precision rifles are a
subset of any military's small arms and
by no means everyone goes for Rapid
International products they are I would
say disproportionately represented in
video games and I think it's because
they look cool so this is uh the Arctic
War firm presumably Magnum because it
has a long receiver suffice to say it is
the bolt action Magnum caliber version
of the Acuras International rifle okay
that's a curious reload there I don't
think there's a reason to open the bolts
before changing magazines on a rifle
like this as with an MP5 or something if
the spring pressure is too much on a
particular magazine system you might
pull the bolts in the rear but I've not
seen that done you'd normally be able to
change the Box Magazine on something
like this and then cycle around into the
chamber
another lever action drum fed shotgun I
would have thought this one would have a
higher capacity because it has a double
drum or what's sometimes called a saddle
drum so you would have feed from both
sides this even has sort of clockwork
wind-up handles on the back that you
would you probably you would need for a
drum magazine like this you'd wind up to
gain the spring pressure the way drums
like this typically work is that there's
a feed Tower in between the drums you'd
expect the whole unit to lift off the
gun and there'd be a feed section in the
middle but the rounds would actually
feed into the gun from this seems to be
a direct reference to the German mg15
aircraft gun which had this style of
magazine Loosely in particular it had a
strap which this has running under the
gun the strap is running across the top
of the magazine because that's how you
grasp the magazine to remove it and
replace it on the gun so this would sing
to be a visual design cue from a real
bit of firearmed Kit that's been kind of
either misunderstood or deliberately
adapted to whatever look they wanted for
the gun the sights are backwards we have
a rear sight that well if you put a hole
in it would function as a rear sight but
this doesn't have a hole and the front
sight is a big U Notch and to use it
you'd have to line up the rear Post in
the front Notch which is backwards to
how you would normally want your sights
to be basically both sites are going to
obscure your target if you were able to
aim down sights with this thing which
thankfully you're not what I had to have
pointed out for me is the relevance of
the name and the Damage effect of this
thing is that if you hit someone in the
back it does way more damage and once I
knew that I could see that from roughly
the rear you take way more damage if you
shoot someone in the back which is a
very TF2 bit of Comedy
that directly affects gameplay
again for watching if you enjoyed this
kind of content please make sure to like
this video And subscribe to the channel
as we'll have new episodes of firearms
expert reacts every Saturday and of
course check out the links in the
description of the video if you want to
help support the Royal armories and
we'll catch you in the next one
[Music]